é
du vaccin contre la grippe pour
tous n'a p d déplacé les foules
dans les centres de vaccination,
cela en a en tout de même décidé
certaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaian
pour la grippe. Je penseçaçaça é
pour ma tranche d'âge,
mais c'était vraiment
Noël seule cette année.
- Absolument! On l'aurait pas
fait sinon. Oui, oui,
ça fait toute la différence.
- C'est excellent.
vont plus se faire vacciner,
j'imagine.
- Pour certains, la perspective
d'une population plus largement
vaccinée les
quand on va magasiner
pour les Fêtes puis tout ça.
oui pour le vaccin contre
la COVID-19, mais celui
contre la grippe attendra.
- C'est pas le coût
qui influe
c'est plus l'impression
qu'il n'est pas si efficace.
- La saison est pourtant
déjà bien avancée.
près de 900 cas de grippe
étététété déclarés au Québec,
avec un taux de positivité
de plus de 13 %.THTHTHTHTHTHTHTu
Département de Biochimie, UdeM
- On est trois - quatre semaines
en avance par rapport
et on est à des niveaux
d'dededede ce qu'on a
quand les vacances de Noël
et les regroupements fam c c c .
- Les personnes de 60 ans
et plus sont les plus touchées,
ainsi que les adolescents
de moins de 4 ans étant
les plpipipipitalisés.
respiratoire syncytial
et une gdodododont la souche
dominante est virulente,
pour certains, pas questioisisi.
- Quand nos filles ont eu un an,
elles ont eu une bronchiolite,
hospitalisation, donc on veut
pas que ça arrive encore.
- Des experts auraient aimé
que la gratuité soit élargie
à tous plus rapidement,
n'n'n'n'n'est pas trop tard
pour le temps des Fête